所以说如果你上过game 101的话
你会觉得这节课无比的熟悉啊
难度并不大啊
那么在这节课的开头
我们会说几个事情
第一呢作业零啊
我这里写的是已经发布了
而事实上是应该是我们的助教
同学们正在努力的工作中啊
然后呃应该是很快就可以发布啊
大家可以期待
反正今天肯定是没有问题的
那么嗯关于作业零呢
是这样的
就是说大家是没有必要去提交
然后大家就去呃尝试上手一下代码
然后我们的文档我看了啊
助教同学们写的非常好非常好
然后大家就按照这个代码来
然后熟悉一下代码的流程呃
差不多就可以了好吗
作业零
然后呃我这边呢把课程的网站哈哈哈给上线了
那么现在大家已经可以看到网站呃
上一节课的ppp p p t里面
我说到了对吧
就是那个网站那个时候还是个单占位符
然后现在已经有内容了
并且呢呃课件的pdf版本啊
第一讲啊就已经发布在那里的
大家可以看得到
之后呢
我们就在课程网站上发布更多的呃
每一节之后发布呃它的呃呃课件啊
然后呢
我个人这边现在我算到有这么一个事情了
我在咱们这课的第四周
也就是啊也就是4月份的6号到10号这两节课
这期间啊
我要我要出差啊
我有点事情
那所以说那段时间我也不知道说网络啊
其他什么条件会不会影响直播
所以我现在暂时有一个打算啊
4月6号和10号这么两个课时
也许是要录播了啊
到时候我再安排看看怎么样
咱们把这个过去啊
嗯至少还有一段时间吧
我在商量好吧
那这里呃这就是咱们这课前要说的一些少
另外呢从这节课开始哈
我也深刻反思了一下
我这第一节嗯说了很多各种各样不正经闲聊啊
然后从这节课开始的收敛一点啊
我要注意啊
然后给大家说一些
这个这真这真正说一些怎么说呢
就实际的内容吧好吧
然后呃更像一个课一点
那么今天我们要说什么呢
是从什么开始呢
从硬件的渲染管线开始
所谓open gl以及open gl对应的着色语言
gl sl的一些基本用法和理解
在这之后会告诉大家怎么样去呃
呃就是描述光线的传播嘛
就是之前我们说到的渲染方程
因为它会在这门课呃
或者说之前在101上
我们就该做这块工作啊
然后我们把这块的知识给补上
差不多
这就是今天的内容有点多啊
又又有点杂嗯
但是讲起来应该还是会挺快的好吧
那么好嘞
好嗯呃当然了
我这flag立的哎好吧
尽量不拖沓啊
咱们这么说
ok那么第一部分
那么我们要说的就是渲染管线
那渲染管线呢
咱们在101里面已经说的非常清楚了对吧
我们呃说了这么一个事情
就是我们最后要干什么对吧
渲染它一开始是什么呢
3d的模型它最后是什么呢
最后是显示出来了一张图
那么中间到底经历了一个什么过程呢
这自然就是渲染管线或者叫渲染流水线
当然这这一个管线的设计就是现代的啊
gpu呃在完成的工作
那所以说呢我们之前电子101学了一套
它背后的这些知识
然后这里呢我们把它回顾一下
那么首先啊物体各种各样的不同的物体
3d的对吧
在空间中怎么表示呢
肯定会表示成一堆点和它的连接关系没问题吧
那么任何的这些点啊
都会经过第一个步骤
就是顶点的处理
顶点的处理经过一系列的对吧
把它给变换到
比如说经过model view projection
在经过viewport
最后给变换成呃屏幕上面的一个点
对不对
然后呢我们知道经过这一系列的变换关系之后
它们之间的连接关系并没有发生改变
所以说之前的一个三角形
它是原来共原来呃是哪三个顶点呢
现在还是哪三个顶点
所以呢之前的呃就是变换过后的这些点
仍然会表示那些三角形
只不过这些三角形现在被投影到屏幕上去了
那么既然三角形已经投影到屏幕上去了
下一步我们要做什么呢
我们做了这一步就叫做光栅化
光栅化是在干什么
就是要把原本一个连续表示的一个三角形对吧
三个点连起来
把它给离散化成屏幕空间上的一堆像素
当然了
它不一定是像素
如果大家是嗯就是用了一些什么m s a a啊
或者一些其他的一些抗锯齿啊或者什么的
就是说这些这些一个一个的这些基本的微元
咱们可以认为管它叫做片段啊
叫fragments
当然在对应direct x里面就管它叫像素
没有任何问题啊
咱们之后也可以就管它叫做像素
好
我们有一系列的三角形
我们要把它打散成像素
那么打散成像素的过程中呢
肯定会涉及到一些关于遮挡的一些处理对吧
然后哪些三角形在前面
哪些三角形在后面
然后前面的靠近呃
camera这些像素或者片段一定会挡住后面的
那么我们是怎么处理的呢
大家应该还记得吧
哈哈好
然后呢
当我确定了这些可见的呃fragment之后
然后我就可以对任何的fragment做呃着色
然后着色呢
自然就是就是去计算它应该长什么样
咱们之前也都提到过
比如说嗯布林缝着色模型
然后这也是大家这次在啊
作业零中要实现的内容对吧
好了啊
那么最后最后当然你就会看到一幅图对吧啊
另外呢这里就是关于是先判断啊片段的顺序
然后考虑遮挡
还是说先做着色
这个其实呢呃不同的处理方法
它会有不同的顺序
这些都是细微差别
那么整体的呃图形学渲染管线
那自然就是这样的对吧
那我们可以看
比如说你有一个物体
你规定了他们应该怎么样去运动对吧
我给了他model view projection
然后我要去应用它
那这当然是第一步
对每一个顶点我都会去这么做对吧
那么如果说我要考虑说哎我一个三角形
我要把它给呃离散成若干不同的像素
那么这一部发生在哪儿呢
这当然就发生在所谓光栅化这一步
我要把三角形真正的给画在屏幕上对吧
大家还记得光栅化这么一个概念
其实就是最早这个词儿就就是画对吗
就是要把它给画上去
那么三角形到底占据了哪些像素呢
咱们之前做过一个非常深入的一个探讨对吧
好嘞
那么还有另外一些呃地方
比如说嘛我们要判断这些三角形呃
各自的这些遮挡关系
哪些离我们近
哪些离我们远
我们是逐像素的记录一个深度对吧
这就因此有了一个所谓深度缓存
或者叫z buffer这么一个东西
然后我们始终去取最小的呃
或者说离我们最近的这个深度
始终保持着这么一个记录
然后我们有新的呃像素填进来
我们来判断它是否被以前的像素所遮挡对吧
那么是这么一个做法
那么到了最后的着色的部分呢
着色当然得涉及到各种各样的着色模型
那么着色模型里面
我们提到过布林缝的着色模型
对不对
那么啊布林峰的着色模型呢
它是一个呃非常惊艳式的着色模型
它是根据观察说我们看到啊不同的物体
它有不同的呃类型的呃
对光照的反应可以这样说对吧
有一些是diffused的
有一些是specular高光
有一些呢是相当于是我去近似光线
弹射过很多次
然后让这个物体没有任何一个地方是完全黑的
那就是环境光效加起来
那就是不灵缝着色模型
那么这套模型呃
呃很显然看起来呢它并不是百分之百的真实
然后他缺了什么呢对吧
咱们在games 101里面提到过这个事情
就是因为啊用即使是用了这个模型
即使这个模型中有一部分环境光的这么一项
仍然他对全局光照或者说间接光照这一块
是一个非常近似的一个做法
那么我们也提到整个这么一套呃渲染的管线了
他确实对直接光照这块是可以处理的挺好的
但是他对任何一些全局的现象
比如说阴影
比如说啊光线的多次弹射
它就处理的不好对吧
这是没有问题的
所以说呢嗯这里就是呃
关于这一套硬件的渲染管线
它的这个好处与不足啊
当然了
它的好处大家可以想象大家之前呃手写的
用用软件去实现的c加加写的嘛对吧
渲染器啊
大家就会发现它会呃挺慢的
然后在gpu上跑慢是非常快非常快的
对不对
然后我们之前还曾经讨论过gpu的呃
它的原理它为什么可以这么快呢
那是因为它的并行度非常的高
他不是代表它的内部的一个单元
它可以运作的多么快
而是因为它有非常非常多的单元在一起运作
这样就是为什么他可以跑的这么快啊
这个意思
那么啊呃还有一点呢
就是说呃我在做着色的过程中
我当然还可以给嗯
比如说三角形的内部
或者说整个一个物体吧
物体的任何一个地方啊
我可以得到一个他的嗯纹理的坐标
从而呢我可以把任意一张图给贴上去
然后根据它的纹理坐标
任何一个位置我都我都知道呃
他应该去文理的哪一个地方去查啊对吧
这就是文理映射
同时呢我们还提到了这么一个概念
叫做呃差值
那就是说啊我知道三角形的三个顶点
它对应的纹理坐标是什么
然后呢我问你三角形内部任何一个点啊
它的纹理坐标
如果我要它有一个平滑的过渡
那它的纹理坐标是什么呢
对吧
这里我们就需要用到插值
并且我们用到一个重要的概念
叫做barry santic coordin
对吧啊
所以说呢这就是这里的呃
关于嗯整个一套硬件的渲染管线这块的知识啊
这是简单给大家一带而过
因为我们之前说了啊
就是说呃
我会假设大家game g101 就已经上过了
然后这块应该不是什么特别大的问题
那我们再进行下一个呃模块之前啊
我先看看同学们有没有什么问题
现在可以啊
欢迎问哈
我来看一下嗯
哦说是三角形哦
它是怎么定义这些
哪些点要连接成一个三角形的
是想说这个意思吧
对吧啊这块我们之前曾经提过
在啊在哪一节我不记得了哈
就是呃是wave front object文件类型
在这个地方我们提到过对吧
我们可以先定义一系列的点
然后把它给编号一到n
然后呢我再定义一系列的三角形面
这些三角形的面啊
每一个都会带着三个不同的下标
然后表示说我用这三个这点形成一个三角形
对吧
然后我可以这么来做
对这是没有任何问题的好吧
然后哦有同学问的问题非常深刻呀
有没有适合全局光照的管线
哎哟我的天诶
可能现在还没有啊
但是但是实时光线追踪是挺适合的
这是真的啊
这之后我们肯定会提的
ok那么嗯再看看哈体积着色啊
其实我不太清楚这是个什么概念啊
也许是工业界的说法
那就先这样好吗
那纹理坐标的uv是怎么参数化出来的
同学上过102吗
这咱们102提到的对不对
就是说啊就是说啊给你任何一个模型哈
你怎么样得到一种合理的所谓参数化
使得你给他任意一个顶点上
然后都对应着一个uv啊
当然也可以通过一些艺术的方法来做啊
比如说你可以认为这个物体外面有一个盒子
然后四面八方它它都会有嗯什么呢
就会把这个盒子给挤进去
最终贴在这个物体表面上对吧
你就可以看到这个物体表面上任何一个地方
它都对应着原本盒子上的一个地方
而盒子上面的uv是好定义的啊
没问题
那么呃就是说关于这块
是有不少的方法可以做的
但是呢一个一个通用的要求是说
你要给这个物体定义的uv
又要满足它能够对你
你的纹理有一个很少的所谓扭曲啊
叫distortion对吧
然后另外一个呢又又要保证说
尽量你嗯你纹理映射上一个物体之后
它的各个地方的拉伸程度尽量还都是一样的
就是说它的面积基本上来说
不要出现哪一块被拉的特别大
哪个地方的都特别小
大家通常会避免这么一些问题
所以整个大家问的这么一个问题啊
叫做参数化问题
这是一个非常非常困难的几何问题
也是大家这个学术前沿在研究的一个事情
好吧
ok那咱们就这样
就是说这门课我看吧好吧
后后续也许会有一个话题上可以跟大家说一下
就是在在什么呢
在sdf上
大家还记得s df吗
signed distance function
距离场了
有向距离场这么一个概念上
也许还会跟大家重新提在有效距离场上
怎么样去给呃得到的一个呃形成的呃
隐函数的表面
然后做一个呃uv的参数化好吧
到时候我们来说这个事情呃
如果我还记得的话
哈哈行啊
那咱们先这样啊
那咱们就开始进展下一个话题吧
或者说如果没有接触过的
没有任何问题啊
嗯open gl首先咱们说它是什么对吧
然后open gl是什么呢
它是一系列的啊
a p i它这个a p i呢它是怎么样运作的呢
它是在cpu端执行的
然后呢他负责调度gpu
就是他负责安排gpu负责干什么啊
这么个意思
但是呢这一套api确实在cpu端写的
那所以说既然这么一说
大家就立立刻可以诶意识到这么一个事情对吧
open g好
本身他拿什么语言写是一点关系也没有的
我们更关心的是gpu怎么样去执行对吧
而不是说cpu怎么让gpu去执行什么东西对吧
这是两个完全不同的事情
所以语言是没有关系的
这就是为什么说比如说我之前学啊open gl
然后我们用c语言写
然后呢呃我拿到比如说用什么拍open解啊
我都不知道他是不是叫popen解啊
拿到之后我就立刻可以直接去用它
我只需要查一些
查一下这个对应的语法怎么用就可以了对吧
然后同样道理
到咱们这这么一个呃作业框架里面啊
他们本身只是负责
咱们可以理解成一个前端的一个事情
就是他们怎么样去调gpu里的东西啊
这么一个意思啊
所以这是open gl
那么open gl它有一个非常好的特点
它就是跨平台跨平台
不管你是windows还是呃linux还是mac
mac的话
可能最近有些什么问题吧
到时候咱们再看吧好吧
然后呢呃嗯就是这
这也是我们会为什么去选择用
喷gl的一个理由哈
因为大家可以看到这里啊
direct x是也是另外一套api
然后也是挺好用的
呃但是呢它只能在windows下面跑
van的这个东西比较新
然后作为我个人来说
我又不太熟
所以说我不敢乱说
所以咱们就用open讲
挺好的
没有
如果没有什么问题
这些呢都是工具
都是工具
没有什么问题
不会耽误大家对咱们实时渲染背后的
一些算法的理解啊
这么个意思
那么open g哦
我们说了它的好处
它有没有什么坏处呢
答案还是有的哈
有第一呢呃它的版本是非常非常碎片化的
什么意思呢
就是open gl
它的它的版本是这样的
它是作为一个所谓community的一款软件啊
这么一个意思
所以大家是不断在上面添砖加瓦
这么就是大家可以理解成
是有一条这个非常平滑的曲线一直在往上升啊
是这么一个意思
这是open gl
然后呢相比于directx
directx
大家知道都是分各种各样版本的
对不对
然后呢呃呃大家会发现a direct 9到directx 10
然后第二个s到11哦
各自的这些新特性的这些提出
这是非常非常清楚的
然后到时候比如说用directx开发的游戏
然后我们就说哦
我们要求说这个显卡要支持direct x
多少多少多少对吧
就这么一个意思
所以它相当于是一个step方式对吧
一个阶越函数可不是一个是很多个对吧
从这一代到下一代
然后下一代再到下一代
而是这么一个意思
那也就是说open gl它这样一个平缓的一个过渡
就会就会让人发现有这么一个问题啊
就是说就是说可能这些不同不同的版本
各自有不同的特性
然后这样的话
就就感觉用起来会不会比较麻烦啊
这么个意思
ok另外一个问题是open gl写的时候
它作为cpu端的api对吧
然后他的最大的问题是他写的是c风格的代码
就是它的代码是完完全全是没有什么面向对象
这一说的
就是说让现代呃
我们的编程人员
写起来是非常非常不方便的一件事
情
就完完全全是是c风格的
然后不好用
这是一个
然后呢另外还有一点是在若干年前哈哈
那大家大家既然已经听到我说这个前提了对吧
若干年前open gl的代码甚至是非常不好debug的啊
现在当然是好很多了啊
这么个意思好嘞
那么呃行open gl呢
那我们说就是这是这是干什么的对吧
那我们干嘛要用呢
因为它快对吧
因为他是用了gpu
我们刚刚才说gpu的并行度非常高
他可以做的非常的快
那他们就用它
而且这是在真正的去编程这个硬件
gpu怎么样去跑
那么我们如何去理解呢
我们刚才已经提到在电影101里面啊
我们会考虑我们所做的每一步
其实在open gl里面都是有对应的
比如说我们花了大力气去推导这么一个呃
所谓透视投影
它的矩阵是什么
到了open gl里面一句话就可以把这个矩阵拿到
你就只用调用它的api就好了
那当然非常方便了
对不对
那这就是open gl
那有同学说呃会问他会不会被ban取代啊
有可能搬的这个这个谁知道呢
对吧哈哈哈哈
ok然后debug怎么办
待会我就说啊
待会会说好嘞
然后啊open角咱们刚刚说到
这是说我们干嘛要用对吧
然后然后现在来说我们得到sho这一步了对吧
那么怎么用open gl呢
那这个时候我说咱们做这么一个工作
我们把整个的一个渲染过程理解成
再画一幅油画的这么一个过程
这样就好理解了啊
这个大家应该也不陌生
因为咱们之前做过类似对吧
咱们在推导所谓viewing transform的时候
我说相机他的这个呃怎么样去理解它呃
也是用了类似的一个拍照的一个过程
那么这里呢我们理解成画油画的一个过程
那么这个过程大家可以思考一下
如果你要画一幅油画
你要怎么办呢是吧
你首先肯定要这样对吧
你首先要把物体或者说模特哎
怎么把放那对吧
这是第一步
第二步呢
那我肯定是要把所谓的画家给放在
某一个位置上啊
大家知道油画它有一个画架对吗
这是一个很重要的一件事情
然后我把画架放在哪个地方
那就意味着我是坐在哪个地方的
所以说我把画架放哪儿
其实就是理解成是诶
我的相机什么东西要怎么放对吧
这个没问题
那么呃把画架放好之后
我画架上要放一块画布对吧
然后因为平常大家肯定不是
画在画架的木板上的对吧
这也是一个重要的区别
就是就是说大家好好想一想
是不是这么回事对吧
通常画叫木的
然后你要在上面画
在上面钉上啊对吧
然后呃一张纸或者是或者是那种布对吧
然后你要所谓的画布
然后你把它贴上
贴上之后
然后你开始画
你在什么上面画呢
所以对你是在你是在这块画布上
然后画上一些东西
然后呃如果说啊你还想再画更多的画哦
那你把这块画布扯下来
然后贴另外一幅画布
然后你接着画
这是没有问题的
那么嗯当然了
就是说如果你感觉哦这角度我画的挺好的
我收集到了几张不错的画
然后那行吧
我换一个角度
然后我再继续画
那就意味着你之前画过的那些画对吧
都可以呃
被你后续的这些呃呃绘画的这些过程拿过来用
而这是没有任何问题的对吧
诶那这就是就是就是说你要画一幅油画
应当去怎么样画啊
当然不只是油画的对吧
素描也是一个道理
就是你需要一块板对吧
然后然后把这个画画布或者纸给贴上去
这一个呃理解这是挺重要的一件事情
另外大家学一个词对吧
ea哈哈这个词就是啊就是画架的意思啊
ok好
那咱们为什么要做这个类比呢
因为open gl
它严格意义上其实就是做的这么a b c d
e f这么六步
ok这是当然我个人总结啊
那咱们看看为什么呢对吧
可能有同学说他这是呃
为什么他会是做到这么几步
那咱们想一想
比如说啊我要呃我要渲染一个3d的场景
那么我们类比绘画的第一步
那我要先把物体和模型给啊放在一个地方
那当然了
这里涉及到两个问题
第一什么物体对吧对吧
我我得我得确定我是想渲染一个stanford bunny
还是说我想渲染一个color box还是些什么东西对吧
我得告诉这模型
说我这告诉我告诉我的程序对吧
或者告诉gpu
我的模型我应该用什么样的模型对吧
这一步肯定得有
然后呢我模型该怎么样摆放
这些跟之前都是差不多的对吧
那么我在g我在open gl里面
我如何去告诉gpu
我要去渲染什么样的模型呢
这个时候我们需要一个呃东西啊
open gl定义的一个东西叫做vertex buffer object
简称vb o
这也是我们一直在用的一个东西啊
就是他是在干什么
大家可以想象这些这个vb o呢
就是gpu中间的一块区域
这个区域用来存储你的模型
这个模型怎么存储的呢
就跟刚才我说的object file存储方式非常非常相似
就是存一堆顶点的位置啊
它自然就会有一个顺序对吧
或者编号
然后呢存一堆对应的real
然后再存一堆他们的连接方式
或者他们的啊
他们的texture的坐标啊
就是这么回事
就是说它以一定的格式
反正组织了这么一个呃物体
应该放在gpu的哪儿啊
大家看清楚v b o啊
是用来存储这些模型的
放在gpu里啊
然后我刚才提到非常呃和o b j文件非常相似
那么剩下的是什么呢
对吧
剩下的那自然就是说呃我要给这些物体一些呃
所谓他们的运动
它给它一些矩阵
对不对
那么这些矩阵咱们之前在games 101里面
我们提到的是说哦
那我可以首推一个这个矩阵a b c这样的
对不对
他的translate怎么写的呃
呃呃比如说他们的rotate怎么写
但是open gl这一切都帮你做好了这个事情了好吧
这是非常简单的事情
比如说你要想想做一个啊三维空间中的平移啊
大家知道三维空间中的平移
咱们之前已经说过了
在齐次坐标的表示下
是一个4x4的矩阵
并且只有最后一列的前三个数是呃
平移的x y and z对吧
它当然容易
但是对于3d的旋转呢
是不是就要稍微难一点对吧
但是这些open技巧都告诉你了
你只需要调用他们
用这些对应的函数的语法对吧
我说了
open gl是a p i啊
他他做了它
它设计来就是用来让你快速的得到这些信息的
没问题
那么完全没有必要自己去写它
那么open gl这一步呃
和绘画的类比
咱们就完成了
就是物体的所谓摆放
好吧好嘞
那这就是第一步
那第二步为什么说和呃这个画架还有关系呢
因为放置画架呀体现了两个事情
两个事情哪两个事情
第一啊是指视图变换呃
视图变换当然就意味着说是你要放相机对吧
我们刚才说了
你花架放在哪
就意味着你坐在哪儿画这么一个场景
那当然这就是你呃
从这个位置看到这个场景的东西
就画在这这个画架上面的布上对吧
没问题
那么这里体现两个事情
第一就是你要放置相机
第二一个更重要的事情
就是说你要在open gl里面建立一个东西
就是open gl里的画架
什么呢
叫做frame buffer
ok这是一个非常重要的一个概念
就是说你需要创建
或者说你之前创建好了
你需要指定你要用某一个所谓frame buffer
意思就是我要用哪一个画匠啊
这个意思
那么这两个意思呢
呃我都可以呃
这呃这两块儿吧我们都可以解释呃
呃比如说呃view transformation
对应到咱们之前game 201里面对吧
什么是视图变换呀
就是我的相机
我的相机是呃呃透视投影的还是正交投影的呢
对吧
然后我要推出一个view transform
各种矩阵对吧
大家想一想哈哈
当时推导这些东西是多么复杂的一件事情对吧
那所以说open gl就让一切都得到了简化
你只需要规定所谓呃相机的一些属性就可以了
比如说它的呃field of view对吧
可视的角度
这些都是呃可以
都都是咱们之前说过的一些概念啊
你只需要去调用这个函数
它就会告诉你所谓视图变换的矩阵是什么呢
大家还记得视图变换的矩阵
最后是要用在物体上的吧对吧
大家应该还记得我们之前说过的
这么相对运动这么一个逻辑
我们试图变换的矩阵
是可以把你现在的呃
camera的位置给变换到一个经典位置的
并且呢为了让你整个一个场景看到的东西
是完全没有发生变化的
那你对所有的物体都要做同一个啊
呃视图变换啊
就是这么个意思好
如果大家还记得的话
这应该不是什么特别大的问题
那么下一步就是你要去使用一个画架
就是这么一个意思对吧
那么呃这一步呢你为了使用一个画家
你是一定要在上面啊
比如说呃固定一个呃画布的是这么一回事对吧
那同样道理还是在这个油画里面啊
在油画里面我们之前还提到这么一个事情
就是说你是可以你是可以用同一个画架呃
来画很多不同的图的对吧
然后就是说你只需要换一块画布哦
你就可以画一个另外一张图
然后再换一个画布
你又可以画另外一张图对吗
所以说呢就这里我们把这两块我们给呃在一块
说就是只要你指定了一个frame buffer
你是可以一下去渲染出很多不同的纹理的啊
这么一个意思
这就是open gl
它的一个好处就是说我们管啊
用一个画家呃去渲染
可以一下渲染多张图
这么一个叫做multiple render target啊
具体就不再跟大家说了
那我们要干什么呢
就是说我要我要啊对场景渲染一次
对场景渲染一次
然后就相当于我坐在某个画架之前准备画
但是我可以画很多不同的这些画
就是这么一个意思
所以我用一个frame buffer
我可以指定这个frame buffer
它可以输出很多不同的纹理
就是这么一个意思
ok哈哈哈哈哈
所以现在这个技术已经不是什么复杂的技术了
就是说我这里简单跟大家说一下
以前是不支持的
很早之前就说一个双buffer只能绑定一个纹理
然后就是说你你画
最后也只能画到一个纹理上面
那现在有这么一个所谓multiple render target
那就非常方便对吧
那就是说呃你从一个角度看过去渲染一次场景
然后场景光栅化一次
你一下可以输出好几张
额管理要渲染出来的结果
可能有一张是你shading的结果
可能有一张是深度
可能有一张是什么别的一些什么东西
这是你自己指定的
这些是由之后的frame by frame fragment shader啊
来告诉这个gpu
说你最后要写到哪一个管理里面去啊
这是可以的
那么呃
这里有一个特殊的一个渲染的目标是什么呢
就是大家可以可以认为有一个特殊的目标
是直接渲染到屏幕
而这个事情呢
大家呃特别在现代的实质现场里面
大家并不怎么推荐这么做哈
就是说直接嗯
我把一个frame buffer里面渲染出来的结果
直接渲染到屏幕上
因为这样的话会造成一个问题
什么呢
就是说你这一帧没有渲染完
然后下一帧又要开始渲染了
那么这个时候就出现你这帧渲染到一半
然后下一帧开始再覆盖你这一帧看到的内容
而这个时候就会出现画面撕裂的一个情况啊
这种这种情况呢
然后通常如果大家打游戏的话对吧
大家就会看到说啊
游戏里面通常都会有一个选项叫垂直同步
如果你把垂直同步给勾上
勾上之后它就不会出现这种情况了
然后呢呃有人的做法
那自然就是说哦
我要先把嗯渲染的结果存到一个纹理
或者存到一个缓冲区里面去啊
当我渲染好了之后
我确保没问题
我再拿去让屏幕去显示啊
这个行为叫做双重缓冲
或者还有一些更复杂的叫做三重缓冲
所以说这几个概念都是联系在一块的
垂直同步双重缓冲
三重缓冲啊
这个意思啊
ok那这里就是说一下
就是说呃我们frame buffer就是画架
然后画布可以有很多张
一下画很多张啊
这么个意思呃
当然这一步就是渲染一次场景啊
或者叫一趟吧
就是pass的概念
然后你可以得到很多个不同的东西啊
由fragment shader告诉你
最后要写到哪一个纹理上面去
这么个意思好嘞
那么open gl呃
我们继续类比之前的这么一个画油画的过程啊
就是说我是可以把啊
嗯怎么说呢
我是可以把真正最最核心的这一部分得
完全类比于我就要在画布上画画这个事情了
对吧
不管怎么样
我画画要把它给把一个场景画在画布上
那么open gl一定无论如何
我要做shading
对不对
那我做shading怎么做呢
那这个我们之前在电子101
已经说的挺清楚的了
就是我们基本上来说呃
即使对于咱们这门课来说
基本上也只需要用到两种不同的着色器
一个是呃顶点着色器
一个是片段着色器
或者叫像素着色器
vertex shader和fragment shader
其他的呢一些复杂的东西咱们不需要啊
暂时在咱们这门课
实现我们说的这些算法的时候
是不需要用得到的啊
ok那么具体怎么做的呢
那大家如果还记得的话
就是说我们每一个顶点我们都要做一个操作
这个操作是谁定义的呢
这就是我们自己在顶点着色器里定义的
如果这个顶点
那肯定首先要做mvp的这个呃呃映射对吧
或者是啊投影啊
做完之后可能有一些东西我们要呃希望它插值
然后我们就把它给呃也给算出来
并且送到呃片段着色器里面去
那么片段着色器里面得到的输入
自然就是顶点着色器的输出
在一个顶点上面的属性啊就会被插值到呃
呃任何一个像素上面的属性
那么做这么基本上就是这两个事情
一个是顶点怎么样去运算呃
就变换了
一个是呃一些需要插值的值
我们把它告诉啊
片段着色器就好了好吧
然后呢呃之后自然就是open gl
它来做的一个事情了
他做的事情就是把一个三角形呃给打成呵呵
一堆的像素或者是片段
那么自然而然呃这一步咱们不用管
咱们就就考虑说啊
当这些片段都已经生成了之后
然后我们要呃嗯怎么样处理
那怎么样处理呢
我们自然要对每一个片段做着色啊
那我去着色呃
怎么样去做呢
我就说呃还是一样
就是自己写片段着色器呃
open gl会去调用它呃
自动的哈
然后我就可以做后续的每一个片段的着色
然后他的这些lighting啊
各种各样的计算
然后同样的道理
就是说你也可以自己去写深度的测试
你也可以让open gl来帮你做深度的测试啊
通常情况现代来说
大家可能更多的是自己去处理这个
深度的测试哈
嗯但是open gl自己是可以做的
没有问题啊
那这就是片段着色器要做的事情啊
那么大家可以看到这么一个事情的对吧
如果说你在顶点着色器的输出
是每一个顶点上的属性
并且你告诉他
这些这些属性在片段着色器中是要被插值的
这部分啊
open gl就会帮你做好
你到fragment shader里面
到了片段着色境内
你就可以认为这些性质或者属性
之前是每个顶点的
现在已经帮你插值好了
它已经是在对应的这些像素上
它插值出来的纸了
你就可以直接用啊
这是非常好
马上我们会看一个例子哈
好嘞
那这里那就是我们这节课
我们最需要关心的一个实际问题
就是说啊我们自己怎么样去定义
怎么样去写顶点和片段着色器
然后其他的东西更多都是可封装的
没问题
就是整个这套这套流程下来啊
基本上来说都是可封装的
然后除了说你要写的顶点和片段着色器
这就是我说为什么
其实我们并不是特别去需要去学open gl这些语法
因为它挺好用
我们只需要集中精力在着色语言上
当然了
这是最近呃
就是说关于整个这一套呃open gl的使用啊
这块咱们就可以理解成directx
它自然提供的就是一套面向对象的一个写法
那自然就会比open gl要好一些嗯
好用一些啊
这么个意思
然后呃甚至比如说大家可以考虑
我用呃各种各样的引擎实际上在干什么呢
实际上相当于就是有了一个所谓呃呃g u i的
一个一个呃操作的界面
对吧
我们可以设置各种各样不同的pass什么
我只要简单的拖拽就可以了
实际上我们做的完全是一个事情了对吧
我们就告诉gpu说我到底要干什么是吧
ok那也就是说关于关于在所谓着色器之外的
这些open gl的这些操作
都是我们不是最关心的好吗
那咱们做一个简单的总结
说open gl做什么事情
就是告诉gpu我该做什么
没问题吧
而且他可以告诉gpu去做多次不同的任务
比如说我这场景我可以渲染很多次对吧
然后呢我要对一次场景呃
对场景我要渲染一次
那在这之前啊
这里是就是open gl
所谓他一个比较关键的事情
它在渲染之前一定要先告诉清楚我这gpu呃
它它它里面他的所有信息都得都得告诉gpu
是这么一个意思
否则的话这个渲染一定是不可能做的
那么为了让这个场景能够渲染
我们要干什么呢
我们做一个总结啊
第一定义说我要渲染什么物体这些场景
然后我要定义这些物体场景啊
他们的mvp这些这些矩阵啊
当然涉及到view和projection呢
就是跟这相机也有关系对吗
我要定义说告诉gpu我要渲染这些东西
我的相机在哪儿
mvp都是什么
然后我又要告诉gpu说我要选什么画件对吗
我我要选什么frame buffer
frame buffer挺重要的概念啊
然后我这frame buffer它的输出是几个纹理呢
是一个还是多个呢
然后都是谁呢
那我肯定要把这些纹理我我给这个告诉说啊
这个frame buffer说这是你的输出啊
把这些东西都给定义好
定义好
然后呢我同时还要告诉gpu我怎么渲染
是不是我告诉gpu怎么渲染呢
那我就把我的作为顶点和片段着色器
我也都告诉gpu
当所有东西都在gpu了之后
然后我拿去渲染
就是说所有东西在渲染之前一定都得在gpu里
这是非常重要的一件事情
当然有同学会跟我抬杠
会说这个说open gl有立即模式对吧
我可以哈哈告诉他哦
渲染一个三角形去吧
然后他就渲染一个
我说你在线上人的眼睛再来一个
那么在cpu这边我可以写一个好心红豆
可以渲染很多次
很多次
这样三角形我也可以渲染出来
但是那样会会非常慢啊
这样的话你的cpu和gpu之间的通讯啊
这个事情是非常慢的一件事情
你应该会要尽可能减少它这么一个意思
所以你不要一遍一遍的去做这个事情哈
ok那么这里就是所谓的open gl的一个基本原理啊
然后嗯大家是是这么回事
就是就是嗯在学open gl的时候
就是肯定会见到很多书会说
open gl它是作为一个状态机模型出现啊
其实作为我来说
我是非常非常非常不赞成这么说的
这么这么告诉新手来说
这不是劝退吗
这是没有任何必要状态机模型
我就这么说
你为了让呃这个gpu去完成一系列的工作
你得明明确确的告诉他
他他他他要的这些东西对不对
场景得告诉他
friend ber得告诉他
然后他你你他要渲染到哪儿
你得说清楚
然后怎么渲染也得说清楚
否则的话他怎么才能渲染的不可能的
对不对
所以说我非常不赞成用这么个词哈
当然他用的是对的
百分之百对的啊
就是说你要治什么什么呃
状态为什么什么什么东西
就比如说你说告诉gpu说好
我现在开始要用这个a frame buffer了
这时候用的一个词汇叫bug
叫绑定啊
通常我也会愿意远离这些词汇
听起来不是多么多么嗯好好理解的哈
是这么个意思
那咱们行吧
咱们现在回到我们刚才的总结上去哦
open gl做的就是这么一个事情
那它是煤炭渲染诶
我都做了这么一趟事情
那现在还剩下一个什么事儿
咱们刚才类比的这个事儿对吧
哎我还可以多次的渲染
并且我以前渲染的那些结果呀
我以前每次渲染
我是不是都写到文理里面去了对吧
我以前渲染的结果得到的纹理它也是纹理啊
我也可以拿来当做我这一次渲染的参考
我可以渲染很多次诶
那就有同学问了
为什么我的一个场景要渲染很多次呢
这个时候大家就思考一下
其实啊我们在game 1
零幺里面给大家提到了一点点
关于所谓shadow map的做法对吗
shadow map的做法它就是一个非常经典的两趟的做法
第一先看light能看到谁
第二在看这个camera看到的这些物体
或者说这些fragment能不能被light看到对吗
那也就是说这是一个典型的两趟的一个算法
然后也就是说这是这是非常有用的
那第一趟我得出来的所谓light
能看到的这些最最小的这些深度
它作为一个纹理
我在b2 趟我再去用它
这是非常正常的一个一个嗯思路对不对啊
所以说这是没有问题的
那就是两趟的渲染啊
这么个意思行
那多次多次或者多烫的渲染吧
都是没有关系的
咱们就以后就说pass吧好吧
然后啊
这样一来我们就完成了一个完整的open gl与呃
画一幅油画之间的一个类比好吧
那呃这里我再停一下
我来看看同学们有没有什么其他的问题哈
光源需要深度测试
也需要没问题
几个光源就要几趟啊
这还真是shadow map的一些问题啊
如果光源比较多的话
那每一个光源都要做一个shadow map啊
然后open就要支持optics吗
诶这是什么意思
是说他们的所谓interoperability是吗
也可以的
是可以的
但是你不能指望shader里面去直接去调用
一个光线和一个场景怎么样去呃运作
我就这么个意思哈
ok
ok我来剪我能看得明白的问题
自定义swap share是可以的啊
呃怎么调试啊
对马上会说马上会说还没到shader
马上就说嗯没有提到一些其他的概念
是因为我认为这里不是open gl最最核心的概念哈
啊ok好
他要best rendering
我会在可能把最后一节课可能会提到一点点
这个是相当工程的一件事情
没有特别大必要讲啊
片段呢我理解成就就理解成像素就好了
没什么其他特别需要注意的区别啊
纹理是不是个buffer
其实纹理在open gl里定义它和buffer不太一样
但是呃可以这么理解吧
反正都是显存中间那一块区域
好吧嗯
一次pass就是一个一个frame buffer渲染一次
可以认为一个场景渲染一次吧
这么个意思好吧
纹理就是张图
咱们之前game g101 说了
ok好的嗯
ok其他的东西是不是装载机啊
这再说吧啊ok好
那咱们就先这样好吧
那我们先进展下一块啊
也是最重要的一块
哈哈虽然这里我讲的并不多啊
就是什么呢
就是open gl的所谓shading language
那它自然从这个概念上咱们可以看到gl sl
然后它是用来干什么的呢
它是用来描述所谓着色器怎么运作的对吧
它是一种语言
用来描述着色器的各种各样不同的操作
而着色着色器的各种不同的操作
是用来描述顶点或者像或者片段
应当如何去运算
最后应当输出什么对吧
这么个意思那行
那么呃就是说啊着色语言
着色语言呢自然就是我们刚才说的定义了啊
顶点和啊片段的着色怎么样去做啊
然后这些着色语言呢看起来都有点像c语言啊
因为他们本身不面向对象啊
虽然有struct啊
以后哈哈哈呃
但是呃就是反正就是说非常像c语言啊
然后它有一些比c语言好用的东西吧
我这么理解啊
嗯然后他不是有一个非常非常丰富的历史的
就是关于呃所谓着色语言啊
最早最早的时候没有着色语言啊
没有着色语言呢
那就是说大家怎么怎么编程gpu对吧
大家就要在gpu上写这个汇编啊
这是真的
上古时代大家就是这么就是这么做的啊
就真的要写这个汇编语言
而且在gpu上这是个非常头疼的事情
而且头疼到什么程度啊
这是我之前真真切切地听说的是呃
就现在啊还是位大神叫chris wyman
这是nvidia的一位超级大神啊
做rendering的
然后他之前说他带过一个博士生
他写不好在gpu上的呃呃呃就是嗯循环啊
这么个意思
就是用汇编在gpu上写不好
循环是说所以说他大家可可想而知哈
这是当时那个时代的难度啊
然后呢自然而然就有人说啊
我们如何能降低一下难度呢对吧
然后大家就想那自然而然我们开发一种语言吧
让他可以编译成呃g pu的汇编对吧
那这就有了最早的shading language啊
着色语言
那么着色语言呢经过一系列的发展
很可能大家都会不知道或者被遗忘的
比如说一段时间之前
nvidia还有一个着色语言叫c g啊
然后啊当然现在来说大家主流的着色语言
大家没话说对吧
肯定是h l s l叫high level着色语言
至于它为什么叫high level呢
那我相信那应该就是和所谓low level
那就是汇编相比啊
那这些语言当然都相当于是更高级别的语言
没有问题
那么他们在directx里面
或者说hl sl里面
他管这vertex shader叫vertex shader
然后fragment shader叫pixel shader啊
这个意思
那咱们这节课说的是open gl的着色
着色语言叫gl sl
然后呢
他呃就是我们说的vertex和fragment shade啊
这么一个组合啊
这么一个关系
那么唉说这个历史啊
大家其实可能注意已经注意到了一个细节
什么呢
大家发明着色语言
这着色语言之后还是要编译成gpu的汇编的
最终最终gpu执行的肯定跟cpu执行的东西
是一样的
他只能执行一些汇编指令用
对不对
所以说他一定是要做一个呃
这个编译的没问题吧
这就是说大家用这个shader language
shading language啊
写出来的所谓着色器都要经过一步编译步骤
然后gpu去进行啊
这么个意思
ok那么呃我们来看一看正常情况下呢
那shader要怎么样使用呢对吧
那那shader肯定是这样的
就是刚才我们说了
就是呃嗯它中间肯定得有一部是要啊
是要编译的
那么在这之前你肯定得写这个shader对吧
写了之后你要把它
你要把它拿来
你要告诉open gl好
这是我写的shader
然后下一步什么呢
那你去编译吧对吧
那他就去编译了
他又编译了之后
那你肯定编译了些什么fragment shader
什么vertex shader
你要把这些这些shader们都放在一块
让唉这gpu过去做着色对吧
那肯定都得指定
那所以说我们就可以建立一个东西叫做program
这个program呢
就相当于是
它集合了你写的所有自定义的shader啊
然后呃再做一个这个程序是program的这么一个链接
这个链接过程其实就查一查
说哦
你的顶点着色器和片段着色器中间因为对得上
对不上
那就各自都是对的
但中间能不能接得上这种运作
就是在一块有没有什么其他问题这种链接
那最后那我就是说告诉我文静啊
好我现在要渲染了
我渲染之前我告诉你
我就要用这个啊
我写的这一套折记
也就是说我刚刚链接了的这个程序啊
这么个理解也非常非常自然的步骤对吗
这是这是没有任何问题的
所以说啊那肯定就是这么做的
那么shader的源文件是什么呢
就是你写的代码
你写的代码是什么
就是一个字符串对吧
这也是没有问题的
那么呃所以说这里所谓编译
运行的这一系列的东西啊
就是呃和在cpu上做一些什么编译呀
链接呀
这就是执行啊
没有什么区别的
就是这样
然后呢这里给大家看一下
就比如说如果大家在这这种c风格的代码下
去写这个呃所谓呃呃着色器啊
就是就是说呃他的从一开始呃
你写好的卓德解到你最后嗯编译
然后用它你要经过哪些代码啊
这么个意思
然后这里大家看标题
标题是f i i意思就是for your interest的意思
你看一下是个意思啊
这块不要求大家写
绝对不要求
而且这是c风格的啊
这种代码正常情况下看起来都很难受的
那么这里干什么的呢
大家可以看啊
我的鼠标在这里
就首先呢可以建立一个空的shader
什么也没干对吧
然后呢他去读一个从file name那里面读一个文件
读了文件之后
这个文件最后肯定是一个字符串
挺长对吧
但是它是个字符串
然后呢呃这个字符串呢你要把它给复制到
大家可以看这经典的c语言的字符串的操作
string coffee啊
这个操作你要把它复制到某一个地方
并且告诉他哦
这就是我的告诉告诉我open gl
大家看到gl开头的都是open gl的api对吧
然后我告诉欧文解啊
这就是我要用的shader的源文件
然后那你去编译吧
这里就是这个事
那编译是否成功呢
然后我要去查他是否是成功
而不是从它的返回值上砍呢
这是非常麻烦的一件事
这当然就是之前大家说的所谓状态机
有很多各种各样的这些事情啊
ok然后那shader自然而然就这么编译的
那那那大家可以编译两个不同的shader对吧
vertex shader
fragment shader
那么我们要把它给链接成为一个program
让他两个人在一块可以综合作用
那么我要先建立一个program
然后呢我要告诉他哦
这里vertex shader呃是vertex shader
他要用的fragment shader
是他要用的fragment shader
然后我就去链接
链接完了之后呢
然后我要看是不是链接成功了呀
链接成功了之后就可以用
哎对吧
大家可以看到这是挺复杂的对吧
但是啊但是理论上这是呃怎么说呢
这些流程
所有不同的程序是不是都可以复用的对吧
这是没有任何问题的
也就是说什么呢
也就是说啊
这open gl的这一系列的这些有很多这些操作啊
都是可以封装成为一个非常简单的操作的
比如说你自己完全可以写一个函数
它就用来读某一个呃
读两个文件名对吧
一个fragment的一个一个vertex
然后呢他他做所有的编译啊
所有什么什么操作
如果中间有错误的话
他告诉你哪是编译错对吗
就这个事儿
所以这也就等于是进一步印证了这么一个事情
就是说我们就单讲这门课来说
有很多关于open gl本身的这些东西
没有必要去学的
这些确实挺麻烦的对吧
这些shader什么link啊什么的
所以说就是说大家更愿意关注的呃
然后我们这课也是更愿意教的对吧
就是说关于shader这块
你怎么样去把咱们的讲的这些知识
这些算法什么东西给实现出来啊
这个意思好嘞啊
当然了
这也就是说明为什么说我看大家讨论说
画个三角形
为什么要那么多行为
你画个三角形也是那么多行对吧
你去呃渲染一个很复杂的一个一个啊
o b j文件
你无非就是多了读这个东西
以及说你怎么样去治这个vb o的事情对吧
就是这个事情
所以啊并不是特别大差别
所以没什么问题啊
好嘞那啊咱们再再具体的看一下
比如说咱们这次作业啊
作业零作业零里面呢
哎大家会问
说
我这时候就把大家要写的vertex shader里放在这
好不好
好非常好哈
因为本来我们作业描述里面就说了嗯
就是说这里不需要大家去写什么
大家把这些东西敲到啊
或者直接复制粘贴到那呃
我们给的框架里面
它就可以运作
主要是呢咱们一起来看一看他都在干什么
对不对
这个意思
那么顶点着色器
咱们刚才说要做两件事对吧
第一件事是说顶点的变换
我要做对吧
任何一个顶点我得知道它的
比如说它的位置
它的位置是由谁来告诉的呢
它是由这个第一行
大家可以看到这个vertex position
然后大家可以看到它是一个呃3d的一个vector
就意味着它有个x一个y一个z
它是三个数在一块啊
然后呢这里大家可以看到一个attribute
关键字呃
trip的关键字指的是说它是一个顶点属性
就意味着这种这种啊属性只可能会在呃
vertex shader里面出
现
在fragment shader里面
你是绝对见不到attribute的啊
这个意思啊
它是顶点的属性
那顶点的什么属性呢
咱们从名字上就可以看出来哦
这个顶点的位置
这个顶点的法线
这个顶点的纹理坐标
而这些是怎么定义的呢
咱们刚才说在建立v b o的时候
你就已经告诉gpo了
然后你这时候只管用就可以了
非常方便吧
而且呢我们说呃vertex shader也好
fragment shader也好
它针对的都是每个呃
说vertex每个fragment要怎么执行
相当于for循环内的东西
那好那这个vertex position说的就是这个啊
顶顶他的位置啊
咱们就不用管什么其他的了
那怎么办呢
那咱们可以知道呃
做model view projection对吗
然后一个顶点的位置它是一个呃呃三个数对吧
但是我们要在齐次坐标下做
那么它既然是一个呃顶点的位置
那咱们后面加一个一点
大家可以看到
这是一个非常简单好用的一个用法
比如说我要定义一个四维的向量vex 4啊
然后我只需要里面给一个一维的向量
在逗号后面跟最后一个数就可以了
那我甚至还可以这样做
比如说a vertex百胜点x逗号
a vertex百胜点y逗号
然后再点z逗号
然后再一点也可以
没问题
非常好用的啊
这个意思
那么这是做第一个事情
第二个事情
顶点着色器还要干什么呀
顶点着色器还要告诉说我的
我的片段着色器里面要用到的一些
要被插值了的量
那这这些量都是通过vin关键字来来指定的啊
大家可以看到说呃
texture coordinate
那当然是我不止是需要顶点的texture coordinate
我还需要三角形内部任何一个位置上对吧
那同样道理呢
发现我们要要做呃
先做三角形内部的反向的差值
然后我才能用它去做shading啊
这个才是所谓的缝shading对吧
咱们之前跟你101都提过
那么这里呢就是说very in这些关键字
这些very in关键字指定的这些这些内容呢
到fragment shader里面一定都很
还有一个跟它相同的一个定义
那就表示说哦
这里就是说我的呃呃顶点着色器要写好
并且送给啊
送给这个片段着色器的东西啊
这么个意思
那么大家可以看到这里他确实写了对吗
这三个v开头的这些这些量啊
都把他们对应的顶点
自己的这些属性给抄了进去
就告诉他哦
那之后只剩下这些v开头这几个量呢
到了fragment shader里面都已经插值好了
这么个意思
那么这里还有一个事情什么呢
就是这里的uniform的关键字
uniform是什么呢
uniform的理解是最好理解的
uniform就是全局变量
直接从cpu扔到gpu来的一系列全局变量
还嗯顶点着色器也可以访问
然后呃片段着色器也有这些uniform
就是它也可以用
没问题
那么这里全局变量是什么呢
大家可以看到从名字就看到了model view projection
因为model view projection这里呢它是理解成我这个运动呃
就是不是每个顶点它各自有一个运动
那就变成物理形变了对吧
那model view projection
它这里就呃意味着说这个物体
整个一个物体在发生一个啊
uniform的一个嗯运动
那所以它其实就是一个固定了的矩阵
model view projection也是我的相机固定好了
它就是一个矩阵
我不管哪个顶点
它都是这些矩阵对吧
它是全局变量好
那么我们就可以这么用
那么同样呢到了片段着色器里面
到了片段着色器
大家会发现哦这些varying一模一样的
对不对
只不过到了这里
这些varying的这些变量
它们的值都已经经过插值了
这么个意思好吧
呃当然这里有同学会问这hip是什么
是指high precision啊
就是说这里是定义说这是基本的精度
这块是相对现在高端一点点东西
而是这里暂时大家忽略它就好
那大家会发现fragment shader里面
这里用到了更多的全局变量对吧
这全局变量呢用到了呃
比如说什么k d k s呀
然后呃光源的位置呀
呃相机的位置啊
这些很明显的
一看就知道这些都是用来做shading
要用的东西对吗
然后这些都是不管我对于哪一个fragment
它都是一样的对吗
就这个意思对
然后这里一个特殊的东西什么呢
叫sampler 2 d
2/3 d指的就是说你后面定义这个东西
指的是一个texture哦
是一个纹理
就是这是sample 2 d
就可以理解成二维的一张纹理
那么这个纹理呢
你是可以通过对它的某一个位置的查询
比如说大家可以看到这里啊
texture 2 d就是查这个纹理
usampler他的这个texture coordinate上的值
这当然自己可以随便定义了啊
2g b a的一个呃纹理
然后我们只需要它的二gb部分
然后他那个a是什么呢
那这就是说我们在fragment shader里面
怎么样去查一个纹理啊
就是查那个纹理在哪查对吧
你只需要这两个信息
也不需要什么别的
ok那么呃就是说关于这个的具体实现呢
那个后半段这还有对吧
然后这些我就不再多说
但是呢有两个事情要说什么呢
就是说有一些一些关键的一些变量
比如说叫gl下划线flag color
这些是open gl给的变量
就是说你最后要想告诉我open gl它的这个呃片段
它的颜色是什么
你就要往这个变量里面写这些值
另外大家还是否记得我之前刚刚说说嗯
你的一个framebuffer
是可以贴很多张不同的texture
同时我就渲染出来结果的对吧
所以你的fragment shader里面
你也可以指定说我要写对哪一个啊
写到哪一个文理里面去
那就是fragment color的另外一些变种
那我就不再多说了
那么呃回到刚才啊
texture啊
不vertex shader里面也有这么一个东西
就是说顶点的呃
顶点的位置经过变换了之后
它应该是什么
你要把它写到这这样一个固定的位置上面去
叫固定的变量上面去叫gl position啊
这么个意思好嘞
那基本上就这么写了
然后没什么哦
另外有同学已经在讨论了对吧
这里什么为什么要对这个颜色做一个什么
2.2
这是什么对吧
这个叫伽马矫正这块呢
我其实我其实在game的101里面该说啊
咱在这这这现在暂时没机会说
之后我再说吧好吧
就是说呃实际上你得到了radiance和最后的颜色
它不是一个线性对应的
之后只要是要显示某一个颜色
大家都做这么一个操作就ok了
好吧啊行
那么呃这里差不多就清楚了哈
然后我现在啊先继续把这块shader说完吧好吧
那也就是说这里就是大家关心的
怎么样去调试shader呢
那么可以说大家现在是非常幸运的
为什么呢
因为在若干年前也没有多长时间以前
那个时候的debug
甚至来说我是完全没有办法debug的
怎么怎么办呢
当时其实有一个工具叫nvidia insight
其实应该念insight啊
就是这个意思呃
然后呃他是在呃visual studio的
就是一块运作的嗯
那么它可以调试gl sl
调试g l s l呢
但是它需要多个g p u或者多个显卡才可以啊
然后呢他如果是h l s l呢
那个时代呃
他就必须得h l s l在软件模拟的情况下去跑
然后他才可以调试
大家可以看到这个非常不方便的事情对吧
这是非常老的版本
没有问题
那么现在新的版本呢
大家就有办法有很多新的办法来啊
做这些关于shader的调试
当然了
我突然忘了这些事情
我没有说shader为什么不好调试吧对吧
但是我相信大家是可以理解的
shader这些东西既然是你在渲染的过程中
我们刚才说了open gl
你想让它渲染所有东西都得在哪啊
都得在gpu
是不是
所以说shader这些东西啊
它也已经是编译好了
在gpu上去运行
在gpu上
你很难像在cpu上一样
你家人一个什么断点
然后呃就比如说执行到哪里
然后呃
或者说你想看到这中间的一个结果是什么
那你就势必要涉及到cpu gpu的通信对吧
像这一块儿你就得有专门的工具来做
这是肯定的
我我可以在cpu上
比如我平常就喜欢这样呃
我要想debug什么东西
我就把中间的一些结果给print出来
就print f出来
cout出来对吧
那这样我直接在屏幕上就可以看到那个问题
是gpu它不行
在gpu上你的一个呃片段着色器啊
这个着色器它负责这个像素
他负责不到别的什么东西
所以他没有办法在屏幕上写任何其他的
什么东西
所以它是一个非常麻烦的东西
它不好debug
但是呢我刚才就说之前就有办法
那么现在就可选的东西就更丰富了
那第一呢呃这个insight呢提供了一个新的东西
叫inside graphics
这个东西呢它挺好
它和visual studio是分开的哦
没关系的啊
这是这是这是一个就是你可以在任何地方用
然后呢它是跨平台的
它不再是windows的了
然后呢他他有一个坏处
他就是他只支持nvidia的gpu
所以对于a m d e s的同学们
哈哈这个会有一点问题哈
这是那个inside graphics的事情啊
当然了
另外还有一款啊这个软件呢叫做render dog啊
非常不错的东西啊
render dog呢也是跨平台的啊
而且呢它没有呃对gpu品牌的限制啊
ok那所以说这块是可以用的挺好的啊
那么现在是这样哈
我再告诉大家
这是好消息
那么坏消息是什么呢
坏消息是作为我自己
我不知道这两款软件是不是能用来调试web机
ok这也没办法对吧
但是啊
但是哈工业界的朋友们肯定会比我更加有经验
对不对
所以说啊我不知道啊
有没有这个工业界的啊
同学们能说一下
就是比如说randoc能不能第八个web gl啊对吧
那如果不能的话啊
就或者说就算能的话也没什么关系啊
就是说我其实呢经过这么些年
就是之前没有这些呃
第八第八个的工具的时候啊
呃这么一段时代
然后我已经练出了一套方法
怎么样去debug
是谁的
怎么样去debug呢
哈哈呃这样还是一样
我要把它给打印出来
但是但是这就是问题了
这就是问题了
我不是刚刚才说比如说一个fragment shader
他只能负责到这个
那刚才才说gl frag color对吧
他只能负责gel flag color
它没有办法在什么terminal里面
再帮你显示个什么东西对吧
他在gpu里面
那怎么办呢
那就把它显示出来
显示出什么来
就是就这就是一个重要的事情
怎么办呢
如果你得出了某一个值
然后呢你把这个值给当成一个颜色
把它显示出来就可以了
那怎么做呢
是这个意思
就是说呢你比如说我要显示
我要现在渲染的哈
从这个camera开始
我看这个场景我得到了某种深度对吧
我得到了某种深度
然后这个深度我大概啊
这个场景范围也就那么大
但是深度差不多是0~200啊
差不多是这些呃
0~200之间呢
那我就把这个深度这么一个值
我就除以200点啊
那这个值是不是就变成0~1了呀
变成0~1了之后
我是不是可以把它传给gl flag color
把它当成是颜色
把它显示出来
显示出来之后
我只需要用一系列的所谓color peer
这一系列的这种对屏幕的这些像素点
观察颜色的这么一些方法啊
我就可以我就可以诶
就直接看到这些颜色
当然你也可以把图片存下来
然后之后再拿这个图片的这些浏览工具来看
那么就是这么一个道理
那么在macbook下面是有一个原声的软件
叫做digital color meter啊
大家可以直接用
那对于啊对于windows或者别的一些什么东西啊
它自然而然就是
肯定会有各种各样不同的软件了哈
没问题
那么这里我再说一次啊
再说一次
不能用这些啊
print f呀或者c out什么
因为这些shader man执行在gpu上的那些print f
或者cout都是这cpu的
所以他是没有办法写东西到到terminal里的
他只能负责自己那一个像素对应的颜色啊
它是一个非常悲惨的一个debug的一个方式
但是很好用啊
大家之后可以试一试
就是说如果大家呃shader啊
一不小心写的不对的话
那得到的结果就是全黑是open gl
是一点面子都不会给的
绝对是全黑啊
然后呢你就可以用这个方法
然后做一些嗯简单的抵押
你你就可以基本可以看到颜色
到底最后是对应的数值是多少了
好吧
这么来做呃
为什么说这个呢
你看嗯我想到一个事情啊
如果大家看过三体
大家应该知道三体里面说怎么样存储时间
可以存得最久远对吧
他们探讨过这么一个问题
然后得到的答案是什么呢
刻在石头上对吧啊
这就体现了一个事情
大道至简啊
对不对
然后像我们这么一种把这个呃
把把这些值给当成颜色显示出来
不是非常聪明的一个做法吗
那咱们又可以立刻可以看到它的值是多少
对吗对
然后呢呃有同学问负数怎么办啊
负数呢你就先加上某个偏移
然后你再把它给呃变成一个某一个职位对吧
都可以的啊
啊到此为止
咱们再停一下好吧
然后咱们再看看大家有什么其他的问题嗯
来看看哈
哦前面大家说的有矛盾诶
有同学说可以调试外部机啊
有同学说不能诶
这怎么办呢
之后这样吧
之后我让助教同学们来收集一下大家的呃
这些不同意见来看看
以及自己试一试对吧
哈哈哈哈ok哦有同学说这叫rgb调试法是吧
哈哈好可以
好歹有名字
ok
ok啊read pixel说的对
没问题
这跟你输出结果是一样的
没什么没什么区别啊
好吧哎呀
所以到底能不能我真的不知道啊
这要看大家怎么说吧
之后会给大家一个结论啊
啊所谓哭大变成了跟这个就不太一样了
哭大的话更多是所谓咱们之前说过吗
gt gpu general purpose gpu
我们没有必要
就是把它跟这个图形学的这个应用
结合在一块了
联系到一块
这个意思就是ok啊
能演示debug吗
尽量吧
看吧好吧
a通道暂时用不着
咱们先不说啊
ok那么我们用的什么版本诶
好问题
这要问助教同学们
大家看看之后
好吧对
现在用的是什么呢
唉但是不管怎么样
咱们刚才说的这这些应该大家都能明白吧对吧
就是呃fragment shader它的输入输出
vertex shader它的输入输出
这对得上对吧
全局变量是什么对吧
这些事应该没问题
不同shader里定义的变量互通的吗
不是啊
嗯ok框架发布了吗
啊对我刚才就说了嘛
就是说呃应该现在已经发布了吧
我猜啊就算没有
今天肯定行啊
今天肯定行
ok好吧
那咱们就先这样好吧
呃这里呃得哎呀任务失败对吧
哎哎得哎就这样吧
就这样吧
啊那那那咱们先继续先继续
先把rendering equation说了好吧
rendering equation我们为什么要说呢
是因为它是一个非常重要的一个概念啊
那么嗯他呢在我们game 101里面
是扮演着非常重要的角色对吧
我们整个的pass training的一套体系
就是建立在它的基础上的
为什么呢
它是一个正确的用来描述呃
光线传播的一个一个方法或者一个等式对吧
那么他在说什么呢
他说你看到的所谓任何一个点p它上面
它它打到你眼睛上
就是以这种米伽o方向呃
过去的radiance呃
它是多少呢
它是这个点本身发出来的radiance对吧
也是往这个方向去的
加上呢加上所有其他达到这一点的嗯
radix乘以b r d f乘以cos 1
把它收集起来就是这么一个思路
那么简简单的一个理解是什么呢
就是说我任何一个点啊
我如果只考虑它的反射
那他自然而然就是要考虑这个点
他从四面八方接收的光线
打到这么一个点上之后
然后并且反射到你的观测这个方向上呃
它的能量是多少
就这么个意思对吧好
那么嗯那么大家可以看这里呢
就有很多物理上的概念这些东西了对吧
然后比如说呃为什么有cosine term呢
我们之前做过一个非常非常呃
详尽的一个分析对吧
因为呃这incident radiance这li
然后它乘以这么cos term
我们要把它转换成对应的啊
a和b有一个i
然后把它转换成对应的呃irradiance
然后这个radiance呢
正好根据b2 d f这么一个函数的定义
它会它定义的就是什么呢
就是outgoing radiance是除以incident irradiance
正好是irradiance就消掉了
交掉之后出去就是radius
当然这是我们之前说的
即便大家现在听起来仍然很绕的对吧
ok仍然是很绕的
然后但是呢就是说呃不管怎么样
咱们在实时渲染中肯定还是以它为基础的
因为他才是对的嘛对吧
那么在实时渲染中呢也会有一些细微差别
那当然这些具体的东西我就不再说了啊
什么是radiance
什么是dr df
咱们之前都已经提到过了
对吧好嘞
那么在实时渲染里面
或者咱们管它叫花t2 里面啊
那这里呢通常会有两个区别
第一呢呃我们说b2 d f的时候
有可能指的是b2 d f
有可能指的是b2 d f和这cos km在一块哈
就是说如果平常咱们不怎么严谨的话
这是无所谓的
咱们就认为不管是说呃就说b2 d f的时候
不管是cos的b2 d f还是原始的b2 d f
但是呃就是呃根据具体情况来看哈
这是一个另外一个呢
就是说呃人们会考虑哦
当前这个shading point他是不是能够看到
比如说呃四面八方的光照
它会会引入这么一个所谓visibility的一个概念
这里就是呃实时渲染中
人们怎么去考虑这个rendering equation啊
比如说我在呃这个点p往某一个方向
我们一个i去看
我知道这个方向上它是有光源的
发出光光线的
但这个光线能不能照到这个点
或者这个点能不能看到那个方向的光源啊
这就是两说了
这就定义成一个visibility这么一个term
也就是说呢他其实啊对于实时渲染里面
人们更多关注的
相当于是说我这啊发出的光线啊
这是li啊这么个意思
然后以及说发出的这个光线
这个这个方向上我能不能看到这是这个visibility
这里就是说我对running equation的另外一个解释啊
这么个意思
那么呃这里就是就是呃实时渲染上和呃
呃我们说的一般情况下的一个小小的区别啊
这么个意思就是通常人们会显示的考虑visibility
而且咱们说清楚这两个理解百分之百等价的哈
一点问题也没有
只不过是说这所谓incident lighting呃
在呃real time rendering里面
人们就会认为这是所谓光源发出的
incident liking啊
和visibility结合在一块
才是到达这一点的
作为incident lighting啊
这么个意思
那这就是呃实时渲染的这么一个理解
那实时渲染这么理解有什么好处呢
那它自然而然就可以处理啊
这个环境光对环境光照的这种理解啊
就会比呃之前呃不写visibility
像要更为直观什么的呢
那我环境光照咱们101里面提过对吧
就是不同的方向呃
过来的光照的强度都是多少对吧
咱们也不提什么radiance或者什么东西了
我们管它叫incident lighting啊
它它有多强啊
这么说呃
就是淡化一下这些背后的物理概念嗯
那么就是任何一个方向可以过来的
光强度是多少呢
它有一张图来定
那这张图有可能是一个所谓cube map
就是这个定义在一个所谓cube的内表面上的
那当然是展开了
就是留个面对吧
也可以是定义在什么上面呢
也可以定义在定义在一个球上
把这球给按照c大fy展开呃
就好像展开成一个
就是把一个地球仪展开成世界地图对吧
咱们之前都说过啊
这就是spherical map
那就是右边这个大家看到的图
那不管怎么样
通过什么方式
我都可以定义所谓环境光照
它这个光源
它从任何一个方向发出来的光照对吗
那这个时候我只需要考虑说
我在任何一个shading point
我往那个方向去
我看这个visibility是不是可见就可以了对吧
那就看这个visibility像呃的作用
那么就等于是哎把这个啊
它实际上的这个光源跟我这能不能看到它哎
把这两项给拆开考虑
非常方便的一个用法啊
这么个意思
然后呢那我这里还会有另外一个问题
就是说啊呃这两种表示咱们之前都说过
有各自的问题对吧
然后这门课上咱们还会再给大家提一些新的表
示
一个新的表示吧哈然后可以先剧透一下
就是一个八面体的表示啊
这是一个新的环境光的表示
但是是非常好用的啊
ok那么这里呢咱们还要提呃
关于这块环境光
既然我们说到了
那我要说一下它的难度在实时渲染里面啊
我们肯定会愿意说啊
我给你一个物体
我给你一个环境光
我要去渲染它
我要看它直接光照
咱们就先说直接光照啊
它的结果是什么
这已经很复杂了
它复杂在哪呢
它复杂在咱们上页上
那就是说我对于任何一个点这个点p对不对
我都要解这个积分我都要往四面八方去看
往往所有方向都看完一遍
然后我把这些每一个方向的贡献都给加起来
或者说咱们积分起来才行
那这是一个fragment呀
对不对
一个像素我要这么来做
那这是不是一个非常非常复杂的一个
一个运算啊
对不对
那我肯定承担不起啊
那这要怎么办呢对吧
那这就是我们要解决的一个问题
后续的三节课咱们会着重呃
关于阴影和环境光照
咱们会说这个话题好吧
这是工业界的一些非常聪明的一些做法嗯
那就是这样
那另外一个话题呢是咱们的render equation
很显然它是一个递归定义对吧
那来自就是就是某个点接收到的光照
很可能那就是另外一个点
它反射出来的光照对吗
那也就是说光线呃可以从光源出发
达到一个物体a
达到一个物体b再打到你的眼睛里面去
这就是所谓的那所谓的间接光照对吧
咱们之前也提过
那么大家可以看这幅图
大家在101里面已经见到了
这就是直接光照
什么直接光照呃
就是怎么判定它是直接光照的呢
大家看这点p以及那墙上对吧
背后的墙上呃
走廊里面的呃
他的这是完全黑的嘛
就是说光线就只会弹射一次对吧
这里就直接光照
那么间接光照呃
比如说咱们认为光线会弹射两次
或者人们会管它叫one bounce indirect illumination
然后嗯把它加在直接光照上面
我们就形成了一个全局光照
然后全局光照就是呃
大家现在看到这么一个结果
那就非常不错对吧
那这里也要提两个事情什么呢
第一就是所谓全局光照
它是两个部分
那么其实大家平常说我要解决全局光照的问题
实则解决的是间接光照的问题
因为间接光照要难很多嘛对吧
而且可以考虑一个最简单的事情
就是光光源打到物体a
达到物体b打到你的眼睛
那这个是不是一个至少一个n平方的算法对吧
你所有的物体a
所有可能的物体b都要循环一遍
那这才是最后的结果
那当然就非常的复杂对吧
那就是首先区分概念啊
直接光照加间接光照等于全局光照
那另外一个概念就是
如果我再让间接光照多弹射一次
我得到的全局光照是什么样的呢
得到的是这样的
那得到这样的
之前在game教练让我们看到过对吧
我们还问过问题
说我一直这么弹射下去
会收敛到一个什么值对吧
有这么个意思
但是这里呢我们换一个角度来看
我们切换一下嗯
直接光照和呃所谓一次的啊全局光照
那么大家就会看到哦
这两个差别太大了
那当然我想要的就是这么个结果
那如果我看一下呃一次的全球光照
或者说就是就是光线弹射两次跟光线弹射三次
它们的对应的间接光照
都加上加上直接光照得到的全局光照呢
那这两个区别如果我来回切
大家可以看到这两个区别呢就不太明显对吧
就咱们讲讲讲实话
这前两张这差别太明显了
然后这后两张差别没那么明显
这就是相当于是呃
在实时渲染界的一个非常重要的一个理论基础
通常大家要解决实时光照
大家其实要解决的就是嗯
多一次半次的间接光照啊
这么个意思好吧
诶上面玻璃黑了
这个问题我之前不是提过吗
哈哈对吧
如果大家在101上这个呃注意的话还是好
还是能
那这个知道为什么这个玻璃这块会出问题哈
那咱们这里暂时先不说这个问题好吧
那就是呃我们所看到的事情就是这样的
就是说在实时现实中
只要我能搞出多一次的呃
呃也就是说呃这种光源物体
a物体b眼睛这么一种间接光照
只要能把这个搞出来就行了
更多的bus我可以暂时先不考虑
ok这就是这就是呃在实时渲染中
大家更多考虑的事情好吧
ok那这里就是这一块这块儿玩
这怎么办呢
这这时间没控制好吧
这是哈哈哈哈哈哈
哎好吧
你看我才课前才立的flag
结果我是最后一块还没说呢
这怎么办呢
这样吧哈先我先
我先看看大家有没有什么其他的问题哈
真的挺久的了
我觉得再再拖不太好啊
啊这样啊
这样我考虑着考虑着大家关于之前的running equation
啊
这块有什么其他的问题吗
我来看一下啊
呃
ok我看有同学说什么radiance呀
这块那这块就看101吧
好吧嗯
没关系
咱们这个不是工业界代码啊
ok嘿嘿
现场工程知道不熟怎么办
那恭喜你
非常适合学这个实时渲染课啊
没任何问题
ok好好好好好嗯
我想一想哈
因为确实后面的东西还有点多
这个是我之后咱们下节课开始再跟大家说吧
因为确实和下一节课可能结合的更紧密一些啊
没问题没问题
少不了这个这个这个知识点不会少的嘛对吧
ok
哎呦我去有同学们呀啊真的真的不讲了啊
今天今天不能再讲了
咱们咱们直接到什么呢
咱们直接到next lecture啊
我也不好意思啊
之后我来我来看啊
有同学有问题说visibility和transnativity
这好像不是一回事啊
ok啊好啊
下节课讲什么
这张图大家之前见过对吧
咱们在呃101的时候
说所谓呃shadow mapping的时候用到过这张图
然后呢呃我们会回顾一下呃基础的呃
shadow mapping的一些一些方式
然后呢呃他会提一些更加复杂的
然后高端的一些做软阴影的方法
那这就是之前咱们没有做的东西了
好吧
没有说的东西了
而新东西然后开始要准备一些数学啊
呃这些各方面的这些知识好吧
然后如果我们有时间再提一下这个moment shadow maps
毕竟是一个算是一个很新的东西
好吧啊这么个意思
就是这就是下一节课要讲的内容行
那咱们今天就到这啊
这非常不好意思
那么在这呢我解释一下这这这么回事
就是我之前说过啊
就是关于呃gm 101之前我讲过很多遍哈
关于英文版的哈
呃然后所以说时间控制还是算是相当呃准确的
会拖那么一点点啊
嗯但是对于这门课来说
很多东西是新的
虽然我也讲过对应的英文课的课程了
然后很多东西是新的
所以说我也不知道讲多长时间啊
就是这么试着讲啊
这意思呃
所以说这门课的时间会相对的不稳定
那么一些啊
而且我会希望可能会有有有一节课
咱们讲的那结束的早一点
对不对
希望吧好吧
那下节课我会讲快一些
然后这这是非常感谢大家的支持
那咱们今天就到这儿好
那就这样吧啊谢谢同学们
ok好啊
我就先下播了啊
同学们
咱们下节课再见
拜拜